tiens vous êtes donc devant le palais
présidentiel que faut-il retenir de
l'intervention des manuels mc - hier
soir ou alors tout d'abord emmanuel
macron à trancher sur cette décision que
tout le monde attendait la tenue ou non
des municipales et bien des rumeurs vous
avez avait surgi hier concernant un
report elles auront bien lieu mais
manuel macron souhaite assurer le
processus démocratique
je vous propose de l'écouter j'ai
interrogé les scientifiques sur nos
élections municipales dont le premier
tour se tiendra dans quelques jours il
considère que rien ne s'oppose à ce que
les français
même les plus vulnérables se rendent aux
urnes j'ai aussi demandé au premier
ministre il l'a fait encore ce matin de
consulter largement toutes les familles
politiques et elles ont exprimé la même
volonté mais il conviendra de veiller au
respect strict des gestes barrières
contre le virus et des recommandations
sanitaires
je fais confiance au maire et au civisme
de chacun d'entre vous dès lundi et
jusqu'à nouvel ordre les crèches les
écoles les collèges les lycées et les
universités seront fermés pour une
raison simple nos enfants et nos plus
jeunes selon les scientifiques toujours
sont celles et ceux qui propagent
semble-t-il le plus rapidement le virus
même si pour les enfants ils n'ont
parfois pas de symptômes et heureusement
ne semble pas aujourd'hui souffrir de
formes aiguës de la maladie
c'est à la fois pour les protéger et
pour réduire la dissémination du virus à
travers notre territoire
service de garde sera mise en place
région par région nous nous trouverons
les bonne organisation pour que en effet
les personnels qui sont indispensables à
la gestion de la crise sanitaire puisse
faire garder leurs enfants et continuer
d'aller au travail pour vous protéger
vous soigner et donc cette organisation
sera travaillée par le gouvernement dans
les prochains jours avec l'ensemble
des élus et tous les responsables sur
nos territoires emmanuel macron a
détaillé d'autres mesures de ce plan
national visant à limiter la propagation
du virus kovy 19 vous savez que la
france est le deuxième foyer en europe
après l'italie avec 2800 cas avérés
alors eh bien le maquereau a donc incité
les personnes de plus de 70 ans
personnes vulnérables ou atteintes de
maladies chroniques à rester chez elles
elles peuvent s'avérer mais évidemment
elles doivent limiter leurs déplacements
et quid des transports publics et bien
ils vont continuer à être assuré mais le
président français a demandé aux
citoyens de limiter à leurs déplacements
au strict minimum
et puis sur le plan économique le
président français compte mettre en
place des mesures exceptionnelles et
massive de chômage partiel des facilités
pour les entreprises qui pourront payer
leur cotisation plus tard et puis l'état
prendra également en charge
l'indemnisation de certains salariés
il compte également développer un plan
de relance économique national et
européen
et puis la trêve hivernale va être
reculé de 2 mois voilà ce qu'il faut
retenir de son allocution hier soir
merci katia technique en direct du
palais de l'elysée à paris